[Applause]
[Music]
okay
welcome to wendy nice to see my darling
how are you i'm hi
how are you good to see you kevin kenny
nice to see you right watching the
effort so who's the most talented chef
oh yeah they're all it's between the
three of us
unfortunately kenny on the end not
brilliant clearly not professional chefs
but what i'm expecting is 110
commitment so who is tonight's family
brigade
mum judith has been cooking all her life
and is a long suffering mother too
ballsy daughter wendy who shot the
famous cilla buttersby brown in
coronation street
loudmouth daughter lindsay who played
lesbian barmaid jazz
in shameless and joining them in the
kitchen is wendy's husband ken
with three strong women to contend with
it's no wonder ken is crapping himself
but he should be nervous because tonight
the family must cook a three-course
dinner for 50 hungry diners
on the menu a starter of spinach and
goat cheese souffle spiced monkfish with
a citrus vinaigrette
and rosewater cream with pistachio and
raisin biscuits
right we're ready yes yes okay good
right anyone ever made a soup at home
yes yeah okay what kind of souffle was
it a proper one i made
crap a man wasn't that possible
sorry no add egg yolks to your flour and
milk souffle base
the secret behind the sweet plate is to
make sure we've got no lumps in there
yeah eggs spinach and then your cheeses
yeah yeah right egg whites in okay
just before it comes out a little bit of
seasoning in there off
so just a really nice sort of soft peak
stage half of it in now
yeah spatula in and twist basically
turning it over
okay molds you gotta be careful not to
get it on the side yeah let's try it
otherwise it's all gonna go out like
caked
sort of grime on the side of a mold
they're not gonna pay for that
now why were you looking at kenny when i
said no [ __ ] all over the side kenny's
eyes aren't brilliant
holy crap okay just lightly tap
down by banging it out any blocks of air
yeah
disappeared good right kenny lindsay
over there yeah judy's wendy here yes
yep any questions right are we ready
guys yes yes
off we go i'll order four comments table
eight
four souffle monkfish for rose water
yeah sure
hello kenny you in there i always say
you're in there okay good i can't get
the rest of the lumps out of this
okay beat it beat it yeah is that okay
yeah that's fine
on order two covers table twelve two
souffle two among fish two rose water
that's right
first four suplex should be in yes okay
let's go nearly there
let's go uh you must be very proud of
them you know absolutely proud of them
yeah but i mean in terms of character i
mean
they're both they're both characters
yeah both characters so lindsay was a
lesbian barmaid right
thank you one shelf top shelf and your
shelf is on there
yeah good girl that's it table sticks in
now you're recording for four years yes
yeah do you feel like silly when you
wake up in the morning
because it's working so hard eyeshadow
short skirt ammo
come on kenny that looks really liquidy
why is it so runny did you whip up the
egg whites i did for ages
that's not gonna rise is it not you've
got more chance than anywhere thomas
wouldn't admission start that [ __ ]
thing rising trust me having you
standing here like
spencer in the kitchen the only thing is
missing yeah is the berry right
start again somebody get rid of it
lovely would you pay for those juniors
please come on quickly they look
brilliant table 10.
good evening james how are you i'm good
how are you good to see you
yes thank you for coming good evening
ladies welcome to the whole family how
nice
is that it's lovely can you cook at home
yes
yes how did home egg i did home
economics at school
christmas day is it a treat today is the
big one
his mom's like my sushi
tonight you brought your family yes
really good to see you all but lily are
you busy
come on man oh hold on a minute i want
to ask you
how many to ask i don't know it's just a
friend of mine she's lovely
she's amazing she's not gorgeous not my
girlfriend
i love the program yeah it's traffic
were you on the bed with yes
and on the show
we can talk about that i've been in bed
with her why not
she won't let me
30 minutes gone all we've sent is three
tables kenny
yes right let's go tony moulds what did
i say
jesus christ now we're polishing moulds
yeah and the [ __ ] souffle is in our
hand
ken and it's going down and it's going
down flat as a [ __ ] pancake
ah come on kenneth in the bin yeah start
again yeah
listen ladies you've all got something
out kenny's the only one who's got
nothing out of the [ __ ] kitchen come
on ken
come on ken come on kenny how did you
wendy meet how did you get together
she was dancing around under an umbrella
and i was sort of twirling around in a
bedroom
in what in hello dolly and hello dolly
were you gay before you met mindy yes
of course please fight come on okay
kenny please get a souffle let's go
play salad salad
[Applause]
that was hard work yes get some water
and clear down yes
well done well done well done right
ladies how are we nice to see you how
was the souffle
i didn't really like it really yeah
didn't we like it you've eaten it all
did you lick that clean i was hungry you
were hungry
so sorry i didn't know you started i
hope you enjoy maine yes and if you
don't enjoy it don't eat it yeah okay
ladies thank you [ __ ] nightmare
now how was it starting fantastic what i
loved about that
was the the creaminess of the inside the
crispness of the top and the lightness
of the whole texture
time results yes lindsey how do you
think you did out of 50 how many 25
25. yeah i'd love to get 40 paying
that's very very ambitious i like that
total number of guests paying tonight
36 out of 50. not
bad yes not brilliant yeah not perfect
however let's get 50 out of 50 for the
main course yeah
yeah right next on the menu i journey to
the bottom of the sea
to get my hands on the very best
ingredients i'm [ __ ] myself yeah
no we're diving in this right and the
diners will be enjoying the main course
a delicious dish of spiced monkfish with
citrus vinaigrettes
that is unless kenny burns the place
down
kenny [ __ ] me trust you
back to airport time the main course
works with monkfish with a citrus
vinaigrette
[Music]
monkfish towel this is the most amazing
tasting fish
five spice paprika salt
pepper monkfish tail in roll
hot pans olive oil in
for the color of that now absolutely
beautiful
base ouch
rest citrus vinaigrette
lemon apples shallots
season tablespoon of white wine vinegar
three tablespoons of extra virgin olive
oil
[Music]
tarragon
slice
[Music]
vinaigrette
can't wait to [ __ ] eat it spice monk
fish with citrus vinaigrette
done let's go how long should i wait now
chef for those potatoes as they go in
the oven
put your potatoes in yes kenny as those
four go in
four more on judith yes your pan is
still
cold they're gonna be greasy potatoes
look darling look let me show you
it helps you turn the gas up sweet oh
[ __ ] hell dude if you look sexy when
you're sweating
yeah right there we go okay you're okay
you yeah are you with me
let's go guys let's go linda yes chef
very good nice color on this paragraph
yes
nice and gently kenny where's your
potatoes oh
oh oh careful stand back come back step
back step back come back come back step
back
kenny [ __ ] me trust you what happened
you've got to make sure it's at least
[ __ ] uh screwed on you know that
huh careful now it's really hot and look
at me hold it there
hold it there and lay it on the end
always lay away kenny yes lay away from
me so it doesn't splash you
try not to set fire in my kitchen okay
good
right organized recipes on the website
so there's no excuse even if you are as
[ __ ] as kenny get on there and get
cooking
let's go right i believe we're ready for
the first table
watch down so one slices and one sauces
okay julie
yeah i can't do it all my darling yeah
yes on there
and drizzle around let me show you the
first one yeah
so a little bit there drizzle round nice
absolutely beautiful good that's very
nice would you play for those
yes yeah good girl well done table ten
go right guys
that's 18 minutes for the first table
yes
time for the ultimate deep sea delicacy
urchins
[Music]
i'm hoping one of my favorite foods in
the world can be found here on ireland's
stunning west coast
and what better way to see it that
tip-toeing across the atlantic on a
seaplane
on your way to the shore
the delicacy i'm looking for lies
somewhere beneath these waters
this is it the sea urchin its spines
might make it look inedible but they
hide
a bright orange row that's rich creamy
and amazing to eat
i've never gone diving for oceans before
and this must be the most exciting place
in the world to do it
the sea urchins are pretty much anywhere
along the west coast the best chance of
finding them is covering as much ground
as possible and that means moving with a
very fast
rapid tide i must be [ __ ] mad
i'll be looking for urchins on a drift
dive in a strong current that will
enable me to search as many of their
hideouts as possible
it's one of the fastest ways you can
move underwater and ronan sweeney is the
man making sure i don't drown i'm
[ __ ] myself yeah
no we're diving in this right absolutely
i've never done a drift dive it sounds
dangerous
explain to me what it is please we're
going to allow the the volume of water
as the tide is falling
to suck us out we're going to have a bit
of a rummage see can we locate the
urchins and see can we collect some
down there's america i don't want to go
back there for now trust me yeah
so keep holding no problem i'll do my
best i'll look after you
our best chance to find the urchins is
to wait until first light when
visibility will be at its peak
that's also when the rapid tide will be
at its most powerful
it's 7 30 in the morning and that now is
the outward going tide it looks very
turbulent very fast i'm going to be
dropped in the middle of that the sea
urchins are at the bottom
i just wish it didn't look so [ __ ]
cold in there
the current is so strong here i'll be
catapulted along the two miles of coast
in just
15 minutes even the seals are struggling
to keep up
it's amazing how the boat's struggling
to get through like that absolutely yeah
point nerve wracking you're going to
have a fantastic dive no i can't wait
they're going to be on the edge with
this one
[Music]
in three hours the fast-moving tide will
change direction and charge back inland
we could end up in the depths of the
atlantic the time to search this spot
for sea urchins
is now
[Music]
in parts we were moving so fast it was
almost impossible to see anything on the
seabed
[Music]
the momentum is amazing you just pushed
along at such a speed that it's almost
impossible to hold on to the bottom
always like you've got a speedboat on
your ass
the drift i've enabled me to search a
long stretch of the coastline
but surprisingly we found nothing and
the strong tide was starting to run out
of steam
if i was going to find this delicious
delicacy at all
my only option was to look elsewhere
my final chance the limestone at mcnish
point
makes this prime urchin territory
or so i hoped you should have a fabulous
start okay brilliant it's okay
hopefully slightly [ __ ] slower
[Music]
i never thought for one second sea
urchins would be so hard to find here
[Music]
we search for hours and are starting to
run low on air
[Music]
and with just minutes left
we found them
[Music]
i was soon back in as many as i could
get my hands on
[Music]
that was a long [ __ ] journey for sea
urchins i'm absolutely frozen
bothered west coast of ireland stunning
sea urchin
jesus christ was that [ __ ] different
would have gone to billings
[Laughter]
sea urchins are rarely eaten here but
sushi chef saya nakano comes from japan
where
urchin sushi is an expensive much prized
dish which is eaten
by the shedload good morning how are you
very well thank you local japanese chef
now you're going to be making some sushi
yes
yes with the urchins and some rice and
some we got there nori my take is on an
irish breakfast
cooking urchins with scrambled eggs but
will the locals prefer to say a
traditional sea urchin sushi little
single
you know living on a seabed
these babies hand dive open up the sea
urchin
what are you doing with yours seaweed
around yep and with a sea urchin on top
i've just taken off the top from there
you get the back of the teaspoon and
just
take them out so how did you cook the
rice i cooked the rice
in a japanese style season with vinegar
eggs into the pan
a tablespoon of creme fraiche a touch of
salt and pepper
fresh chives now fresh the urchins
right at the very end sarah how are you
doing very well
quick taste wow
beautiful huh beautiful nice
scrambled eggs finished with fresh sea
urchins fly away
do you have sushi with a sea urchin it's
beautiful isn't it it's a lot of flavor
it's delicious the first time you see
your chicken yeah
this amazing local delicacy was a big
attraction in hallway
but which went down best with sea urchin
sushi
scrambled eggs yes do you like scrambled
eggs like that the locals enjoyed both
dishes but in the end my modern approach
of urchins was scrambled egg came out on
very nice very nice
people called my punches i don't eat
sushi for breakfast
no no okay
come on we've only sent two tables each
who's doing what there i'm doing the
next batch of potatoes asparagus for the
next flight chef
okay so why is anyone putting the
asparagus potatoes on the plate
letting those ones slice well i sliced
but you'll have to move that over there
which way am i going left or
come on guys come on come on come on put
the tray down
there's no space there is [ __ ] space
you make space there
bang bang bang bang bang right burn
potato not good enough
yeah it's great now our favorite chef
don't say delia don't say no
yes not an idea that's just porn
i catch dad watching about two in the
morning
dad's watching you just switch oh no
i'm not expecting you around he's
jamie oliver right he is the reason i
started cooking he's the reason
he's here no because it was all funky
and trendy and he's to slide down that
ballista i thought i want to do that
i don't want to go down that bannister i
don't even know what a porcini mushroom
was at the time i wanted to cook with it
you know i don't know that little [ __ ]
can't sign the banner son anymore
because i love the man i'm at 15 next
week oh yeah
yeah filming kitchen nightmares
how many more have we got to do gently
not that many you've got four tables
left yes
okay so this is one a little bit thicker
nicer yes
really nice stop please stop you don't
say nothing until i say i want to see
them yes
let's go right lindsay yes chef are you
happy with those i'm very happy
so you should be checking let's go judy
yes is that right when you
celebrate your 60th birthday you ran
your first mini triathlon
what's harder that or this this
let's go guys last two tables yes
they're in the oven come on kenny
you can do it we're nearly there we can
get 50 out easily how long are those
gunfish in the oven now ken
potatoes are nearly ready i don't know
how long it takes okay hold on here's
the thing
i only asked one table yes they're doing
a five you've got a six
i've got no you asked me for five and a
six eleven do you remember
yeah no we sent them no that was an old
one no
look what's on the ball don't argue with
gordon shut it get up
you can't think that fast there's
nothing in the oven at the moment
oh yes there is yes there is yes there
is yes there is
yes okay what's in the oven
fish is it gordon sir
okay good go 11 please come on guys
judith what's it like having [ __ ]
frank spencer as a son-in-law
he's brilliant rap he is brilliant yeah
yeah
bless go please go go go jesus
rice well done
[Music]
how are we guys very good nice to see
you yeah very well deep thank you who
wasn't happy with the main course
me and my friend here tell me what you
thought about it toes
two of them were fine i know you need a
bit of texture i think that you know
with the monk fish but
i think two of them were a little bit
underdone they were quite hard i don't
know why that works
how did you find that um um however
we're light a bit spicier
a bit spicy yeah yeah yeah what about
the stitches when we get how was that
with a monk fish that was perfect here's
what bugs me
yes all your mates are here yes they've
all got shirts and ties on
you've got one and you look like the
sack of [ __ ]
do me a favor don't pay for it get
yourself a new [ __ ] shirt yes
i hope you enjoy the dessert yeah for
the [ __ ] sun bed
it's tender it's tasty it's really oh
it's just absolutely beautiful the
flavor's really complimented
okay results yes for my course here we
go jose okay
right and here are the numbers uh kenny
how do you think we did quite well i
think quite well
lin's i'm going to be brave enough to
say 45. 45
yes i love the confidence in those eyes
come on okay the number of diners yeah
they're willing to pay for the main
course
is come on oh damn 45 out of 15.
[Applause]
really well done yes seriously 45 out of
50. that's not perfect but it is
[ __ ] good well done let's get 50 out
of 50
yes okay for dessert yes
absolutely roasting hot that was manic
but fun when you start off you kind of
think oh yeah it's fine i've got it
under control there's something other
than it does so when you go in it where
you've got golden counted
table six table of five five and six i
went to five and six kenny did you get
that five and six
yeah thinking about kenny i don't think
gordon is that impressed with him
um i don't think he'll be offering him a
job
next on the menu jerry halliwell throws
a weight around in the recipe challenge
you are so bad janet street porter
settles into the good life
and the brigade cook a spectacular
dessert rosewater cream with pistachio
and raisin biscuits
welcome back to the f word now time for
the part of the show where i take on a
celebrity guest and beat them at cooking
their favorite dish what is it
it's spanish meatballs my mother's dish
now are you ready
are you ready i have born ready oh god
so joe's doing a classic spanish
meatball from her mother's recipe i'm
gonna do something very simple um just a
really nice
meatball but just cooked in a light
tomato sauce finished with um
chili grated garlic and caramelized
shallots
i'm just going to start the sauce give
me some instagram your dish mum's
my mother's spanish okay spanish
meatballs are kind of like a tradition
in my household when i was little girl
she used to let me roll the meatballs
yes and so i kind of wanted to do
something that was a little bit special
i think my mom's really proud of this
recipe so what's in there right now
there's onions in there
minced beef garlic yeah we're gonna put
some soyas oh do you know what's in
there
sherry i love sherry actually the other
girls used to take the piss out of me
for
liking cherry jerry's mixing her peasant
food and i'm making some proper food
breadcrumbs milk that keeps it really
nice and fluffy
inside i'm using white flour really it's
kind of meat cake
but i'm going to be so gordon about it
look no measurement why do you put it
all in so i can win
this is the fun bit go on ready going in
that's garlic and chili sweaty down so
now i'm going to make
roll them these are a little bit maybe a
bit on the eggy side
maybe i'll put too much sherry in was it
good getting back together as a spice
girls
oh it was amazing i thought i was making
amends do you mean i wanted to do things
differently
i felt a bit crap about walking out so i
really wanted to show up and i knew that
i probably won't
you know sing anymore so you're not
going to retire from singing now
surely i don't think i'm going to do it
i think i'm an anymore
i like writing and creating sure anyway
i'll never consider myself like you know
like mariah carey that's or
or tina turner that's going to do it
forever so in terms of being creative
um the next big thing is the writing yes
eugene lavender
why children's stories you can think of
the craziest things yep
i love it really you get to play god
once the tomato sauce is reduced down
i'm gonna finish it with green olives
some fresh basil in our family at
christmas we have
a competition who can eat the most
meatballs seriously
yeah how many balls at any one time have
you had in your mouth
oh stop don't look at me like that no
you are so bad
i don't mind getting a bit mucky right
should we cook first we'll have a fight
after okay yeah when you
all started off as a spice girls yeah
living together who do they cook
everyone used to eat their own thing i
remember victoria eating lots of
frosties
seriously and then mel b would do a fry
up i love those
ironically emma used to eat baby food
no no you've had an emotional
relationship with food you absolutely
when i fell out of control i tried to
control
my body with you know instead i mean the
hardest time is when you had a problem
with bulimia oh that's hideous and how
did you get out of it i mean
i mean you know what just by really
being open and honest about it that's
amazing
oh yours look beautiful oh my god
that's what i'm going to win i'm so glad
you like the shape of mine it's really
good
do you know what mine are made with love
yeah now i'm going to get my bean balls
in the pan
color them and then finish cook them in
the sauce so in here now we've got the
shallots the chili the garlic the white
wine the oregano the fresh basil the
chopped tomatoes
and finished with the green olives
before we move on just one quick yoga
position something i can learn
okay let's do it by the kitchen door
i know that's better lie down on the
floor oh jerry
okay this is gonna be called a plow
[Laughter]
your legs over your head that's it relax
that's it
okay that's going to give you energy
it's giving me a [ __ ] headache right
breathe
that hurt okay well done
is that it that was it that's that's it
seriously yeah there's a shoulder stand
is that normal for all the blood to rush
to my car that's good and then you get
kind of a bit of an energy wrap
it's like caffeine jesus christ okay my
source is simmering away that smells
very authentic delicious it's
cherry oh my god
jesus christ jerry's on fire bloody hell
no right both meeples have to simmer for
10 minutes each so we come back some of
the blind tasters
joey loses simple as that how is it it's
really good
now the mad cow finally gets some calves
of her own
for the last three series i've had all
sorts of animals in my garden
turkeys
[Applause]
[Music]
there have been times when it's really
driven me crazy and even
a hairy hippie you shouldn't feed them
for
24 hours before slaughter but this
series we're going
even bigger veal calves my garden is
just not big enough so i'm getting help
from a very
different beast
she may be a bit long in the tooth but
i've challenged janet street pensioner
to become a mother she'll raise two veal
calves at a home in the yorkshire dales
over the next three months i'm going to
make the dobbyist karen tv
handria her very own calves stop eating
that and finish your lunch
stupid animal to provide delicious
british meal for the f word restaurant
but is janet ready for motherhood we're
gonna find out as she's here to buy
two six-week old cars well i can't
believe i'm doing this
a woman who's had four husbands no pets
i can't believe that i'm gonna have to
look after animals
the best way to get prime veal stock is
at a cattle auction
i'm not exactly uh genetically bred to
care for things but first she's got to
decide which calves she likes
and how far she's willing to stretch for
them
she's gonna need some help oh my god
you know i've never had any pets i once
had
two cats and i gave them away these are
not pets
they're food well yes they're not going
to get emotionally attached to them
the bottom line is dinner
to me they all look exactly the same
yeah they're black they're white they're
sniffing
well they've got big ears with yellow
tags on how do i choose a good one
if this was a group of men and you
walked into the room which one would you
choose to take home
you wouldn't want the shrinking little
violet in the corner
[Music]
i've always liked very weird men i have
married and live with some extremely
tall fat short old young you've got to
look something that will fill the jeans
a
hunky male a hunky male
you know you're so sexy you're looking
for the basketball player
a good strong beast
[Music]
just slide your hand down underneath and
feel it oh do i have to
come on the nether regions
i've had a feel god knows what bit i was
feeling
how much would you pay if i was i'd be
happy to go to
90 pounds for that 90 quid you buy the
best you end up with the best
[Music]
janet's always been full of ball but
now's the chance to show she can hold
her own in auction
for the first time in a long time janet
might just be the youngest person in the
room
this clearly gives her a mental edge
over the other bidders
[Music]
right that's way more than you said they
take credit cards
janet's brought her calves all she has
to do now is to get them home
you've got to go a good eight foot yep
five foot oh no tell me how do i
you could just have an inch what one
inch
that widened me up yes i need a bit of
help here
oh no that way this way no i'm done
light bid for freedom
[Music]
she might be a tough nut but veal is a
subject close to janet's heart
i've campaigned against supermarkets
excuse me not exactly oxford street i've
been out on the streets
trying to make people aware you eat veal
no no no and still this fantastic
me is going to waste so i'm back
on the war path again
no janet if they get past you at last
it's time for janet to find out what
being a farmer's really like
i'm shaking
oh my god it's so slippery
ah there you go right
come on there you go
there you go right
[Music]
there that one is still trying to get
out
[Music]
there you go right warm
dry well bedded draught free
good ventilation so in their terms is
this five-star accommodation
is that it's absolutely five-star
accommodation they are
you're in your new home i've been eating
after you're going to get some food
come here you come on right do you want
to put your head in there
why don't you just try it come on oh no
stop gumming me janet's maternal
instincts
are already shining through let's hope
she can suppress them in 12 weeks time
when it's time to cut the open strings
out of the abattoir
[Music]
what you want
[Music]
janet street farmer nice to see you my
dolly how are you
hi i don't smell them no you don't smell
of um
cow [ __ ] at all you smell nice now has a
good life it's a bit of a poison chalice
you've given me actually gordon
thank you very much for husbands no
now i'm having to deal with two cars
i've had the turkeys yes i've had the
pigs the sheep i thought it was your
turn i thought
they're big and they possible all the
time i'm finding it quite a struggle
i'm really excited but i'm nervous about
you having them i want
only the best in the future you know you
know how funny i am i know i'm
encouraging them i'm good being very
calm
i'm not transferring my aggression to
them good
promise mike's talking about
transferring have you considered
breastfeeding or are you feeding with
the teats
i feed them with a bucket gordon
goodness everything
look after the reveal yes i will thank
you look after them
okay understand what you're doing yeah
out of 50 yes
right are we ready yes yes let's go all
right ken yeah
i'll find you okay kenny okay julius yes
thank you are we starting to slice guys
right time for dessert rosewater cream
with puff pastry biscuits filled with
pistachio and raisins
[Music]
first thing cream
whisk icing sugar
creme fresh
rose water one cap two caps
mix that up just hanging off little
taste
[Music]
get your spoon curl on
strawberries rose petals
they're just dipped in egg whites
sprinkled with sugar and allowed to dry
overnight
into the fridge to set biscuits crush
your nuts bash
pistachios nice raisins
mix puff pastry
butter cinnamon
and then sprinkle generously honey
brown sugar cinnamon
roll nice and tight chill
slice butter
icing sugar 10 minutes 200 degrees
absolutely beautiful
[Music]
rose water cream with raisins and
pistachio biscuits
[Music]
done so we need 100 biscuits in yes
kenny yeah yours aren't even cooked yet
and they look like a pile of [ __ ] what
are you doing no
huh that roll looks too soft is it not
worth persevering with them
listen biscuits yeah that is [ __ ] i'm
just gonna
have another go another treat well i've
got three trays now
good hold on wendy make three trays in
go girl
come on kenny get one in come on kenny
get one in
guys be careful your biscuits yes if
they start burning we're going to start
again they're nice
i can't take put more in there
they look like they're ready though
let's go ahead and get them out
so here we go this is the tree you're
about to find one
strawberry are you mad we've already got
one dog it's not another isn't kenny
enough
holy baby
just four and four after that is a six
chase taste taste spoon ready kenny
the lights are on but have you come home
yet
you want a spoon how old are you uh 42
christ almighty that's amazing you see
here's the thing
you're actually older than wendy and you
look like wendy's toy boy i know how do
you manage that it's years of
just smiling when you don't need to six
now see you've done
too little smiling i've been too little
smile thanks for the lecture you've done
two little work
go well done kenny he's back
next on the menu jerry halliwell gets
her chops around my balls oh my god this
is really good
good luck has james corden bitten off
more than even he can chew
and the brigade finds out if they've cut
it in the f-word kitchen
the number of diners paying for dessert
[Music]
is
right welcome back to the f word now
time to plate about meatballs and then
have blind taste will taste and jerry
will lose ready
jose please come back and put jerry out
of her misery
excellent
oh my god this is really good good luck
[Applause]
very nice there's a lot of depth in that
sauce to be fair
slightly sweet please peppers coming
through i think with the one with this
one you get
more of the meat coming through i can
taste the basil quite strongly in this
one
come on jose i like it when you smile
that means you're bringing us good news
yes
well yes it was very close very close
very very closely
very close put jerry out of misery who
won the recipe challenge
was gordon yes yes yes yes yes yes
girl
nil yes oh jesus christ
i tell you what i really really want you
to do now yes is
get to [ __ ] out my kitchen get out
gutted
it's kind of a spring into summer
pudding
it's really really tasty right
hi it's good to see you now i've heard
on the great vibe that you are a big fan
of chinese food i love chinese i think
it's great
i live with other chinese how much you
spend in there a month oh
some months nothing other months you
know five
six seven grand
so you love chinese food yes i love it
you think you know your chinese food i'd
like to think i'm a connoisseur
are you aware of chinese delicacies
i've heard of some of them now there's
tons
of chinese delicacies that take aways
don't even list we're going to find out
right now which is bigger yeah your
belly or your bollocks
are you ready yes i love chips right
you're going blindfolded yes you've got
either okay
oh come on are you ready
yes
okay you're all just gone or something
right it's like the oldest joke ever
take it off though
[Applause]
well i can see his mum going how's mum
going
just in the first thing is uh
an amazing chinese delicacy that they
actually believe help to reduce wrinkles
now okay
open your mouth okay yeah and off you go
what is that oh a mouthful
it's not a mess i wouldn't do that to
you yeah i love you
[Applause]
your tongue around the toenails that
yeah is
a beautiful poached chicken's feet
[Laughter]
don't you like that what worries me is
that that's number one these things
normally go from bad to worse
come on okay yes now the chinese
strongly believe
this delicacy if you eat lots of them
you'll have a very harmonious marriage
this is extraordinary yes
[Laughter]
and she goes what do you think it is
have a little guess
cat's bottom
right the next one yes yeah now this
yay this has been specially
marinated yeah okay okay it takes
months to prepare right okay why stinks
okay
and take it off
well done yeah we've got one
final thing yes here we go now this
is a special delicacy that's reserved
for a special chinese banquet
only the guest of honor gets this one
you get the
ultimate pleasure the eyeball
oh yeah hold on come on come on
now you are so close
come on yes it's only an eyeball it's
only an eyeball yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
well that's disgusting well done how do
they do
that well done thank you
welcome well done
right time for results yes or dessert
right jose how do you think you're done
thank you i think we did really well you
think we did really well
i'd love to say more than 45 but i'm
going to say 43. 43.
okay i can tell you the number of diners
paying for dessert
is
48 hours
[Applause]
excellent the two that decided not to
pay for that they believed to be uh
it took bland yeah
hold on man 48 loved it two people
didn't kick the [ __ ] out yeah
well done 36 out of 50 for your starter
45 out of 50 for your main
and an amazing 48 out of 50 for dessert
now thanks for watching if you want to
be here visit the f1 website see you
next week don't be late
for your table
you